Nos dicen que: "Un circuito electrónico tiene
dos resistores con las resistencias R₁ y R₂
conectadas en paralelo. La resistencia total del
circuito Rt está dada por esta fórmula. Supón que
aumentamos el valor de R₁ mientras mantenemos R₂
constante. ¿El valor de Rt aumenta, disminuye o
permanece igual?" Entonces, pausa el video y
trata de responder esta pregunta. Muy bien,
ahora trabajemos juntos en esto. Algunos de
ustedes podrían estar familiarizados con la
idea de un circuito electrónico, resistores
y lo que representan, pero realmente no es
necesario conocer esto para entender lo que
está sucediendo en esta expresión. Hay cierta
cantidad Rt que es igual a 1 entre, y luego en
el denominador tenemos 1 / R₁ + 1 / R₂, entonces,
si aumentamos el valor de R₁ mientras mantenemos
R₂ constante, ¿qué sucede? Pues esto va a aumentar
y R₂ será constante, así que una forma de pensar
en esto es que tenemos dos variables aquí, en este
denominador, aunque realmente en toda esta expresión,pero si R₂ va a ser constante en realidad sólo
tenemos que enfocar nuestro análisis en R₁. Si R₂
es constante, eso significa que es sólo un número,
podría ser un 2, podría ser un 5, podría ser π,
lo que sea, pero eso no va a cambiar a medida
que aumentemos el valor de R₁, así que pensemos
en lo que está sucediendo aquí. Si R₁ aumenta,
¿qué implica esto para 1 / R₁? Bueno, si
aumentas el denominador entonces vas a
disminuir el recíproco de eso, eso significa
que todo esto de aquí va a disminuir. Ahora,
si 1 / R₁ disminuye, ¿qué va a pasar con 1 /
R₁ + 1 / R₂? ¿Esta expresión completa aumentará
o disminuirá? Bueno, esta parte se mantiene
constante, R₂ es constante, entonces 1 / R₂ es
constante. Imagina que R₂ podría ser un 2 o un 3,
entonces esto debería ser ½ o ⅓ , o lo que sea,
mientras esta parte de la expresión disminuye,
por lo que, si estás tomando la suma de dos cosas
y una parte disminuye y la otra es constante,
entonces significa que todo esto va a disminuir,
así que el denominador de todo esto disminuye.
Ahora, si todo el denominador disminuye,
si 1 / R₁ + 1 / R₂ disminuye, ¿qué va a pasar con
el recíproco de eso: 1 / 1 / R₁ + 1 / R₂. Bueno,
si algo disminuye, su recíproco va a aumentar,
si el denominador es cada vez más pequeño,
1 entre esto resultará en un valor cada vez
mayor, por lo que el valor de Rt aumenta si
R₁ aumenta y R₂ es constante. Y para aquellos de
ustedes que saben de resistores, que son los que
determinan qué tan bien puede fluir la corriente a
través de un circuito, esto también tendrá sentido
intuitivo, pero no necesitan comprender los
resistores para analizar esto matemáticamente.